live at 11 live local now still
developing at 11 a
child has died after being hit by a car
happened in the east valley tonight
thank you for joining us at 11 i'm brian
loftis
and i'm denise valdez that crash
happened just after 6 30. police were
called to the area
near boulder highway and desert inn
sasha loftis is there live with more on
this tragic accident
denise and bryan police just call this a
devastating turn of events here at this
apartment complex where a little boy
was hit and killed earlier this evening
officers say
this all happened just after 6 30. the
child was riding his bicycle in this
parking lot when a man driving a truck
made a left turn
and the two collided the eight-year-old
was taken to sunrise hospital where he
later died
police call a situation like this rare
and horribly tragic
officers also say this is a sobering
reminder
to be aware while behind the wheel
incidences like this make you
contemplate on circumstances
and you know we hope that people take
this as an opportunity to reflect on
you know if if i'm in these
circumstances where i see these
circumstances
what can be done differently
police tell us the driver in this case
did stay on scene and cooperate with the
investigation
at this time it does not appear that
driver will face any charges police say
that
neither speed nor impairment appear to
be factors here of course this is still
a developing situation
so stay with 8 news now for the latest
on this reporting live tonight sasha
loftis
8 news now